well they're more than 20 Democrats
campaigning to be next presidents and
with so many options you think the
Democratic voters would have a lot of
choices but really they don't have a lot
of choices they'll only control the
cosmetic appearance of their next
candidate they can decide whether their
nominee will be running to be the first
Hispanic president or the first female
president or the first gay president but
in everything that actually matters in
other words what they believe they're
pretty much the same all than we running
on a platform of open borders open
prisons free healthcare for illegals etc
and all of them have the same tone of
their campaign they all spend the
election campaign asserting their
superiority to the country they deserve
to be present not simply because they're
better than Donald Trump
but because morally they're better than
you two on the campaign trail Bernie
Sanders has been zealously demanding
that other people and other businesses
increase their minimum wage to $15 an
hour for example he's accused Walmart of
paying its employees quote starvation
wages
he's also celebrated workers who have
protested and gone on strike to demand a
pay increase right now watch this I want
to applaud the thousands and thousands
of workers from coast-to-coast people
who worked with mcdonalds people worked
at Burger King people who work all over
this country who have stood up over the
years and demanded that the federal
minimum wage should be raised to a
living wage 15 bucks an hour okay well
he couldn't have been clearer about that
so you would expect in the way that he
lives Sanders would set a good example
for the rest of the country but it turns
out you may have guessed this bernie is
so confident that he is a deeply good
person and his causes just but he's just
not sack allah the same rules that he
wants everyone else to follow for
example right now Sanders's campaign is
battling its own campaign workers they
say they're being paid the same
starvation wages that walmart employees
get less than 13 bucks an hour huh
Sanders hasn't budged though if they
aren't happy they can go work on another
campaign or they can quit that's his
position if his presidential campaign
doesn't work out maybe you should manage
a Walmart you probably be pretty good at
it based on his management style
Burnie isn't the only candidate who
can't match his own rhetoric about
staffer pay though there are many Kamla
Harris for example is also running on a
platform of being morally superior to
everyone else and particularly to you
your amoral
she says America itself is sexist and
then her administration is going to
punish American businesses for being
sexist wasn't I'm going to shift the
responsibility to the big corporations
to require them to prove they're paying
people equally for equal work harris
promises that when she's president
united states and don't kid herself she
could be when that happens companies
will be hit with big fines for having a
pay gap of even 1% between men and women
if her administration decides that that
gap is unjustified so that raises the
obvious question what's the pay
structure like it camel Harris's own
office what turns out that Harris is
paying women only ninety four cents for
every dollar men earn huh it isn't just
pay where Democrats aren't measuring up
the demands they impose and everyone
else however there are many measures by
which and I'm measuring up kirsten
gillibrand has hopped on every single
left wing fat in the past five years
there isn't one she hasn't embraced
wholeheartedly two years ago that meant
that she led the push to force out Al
Franken member poor Al Franken the
hapless senator from Minnesota he had to
leave office thanks to Kirsten
Gillibrand there was no proof he done
absolutely anything really seriously
wrong he was a jerk it he acted like one
but he wasn't a rapist you never know
the way that she acted afterward
Gillibrand looked back and justified
herself she said she wasn't leading a
lynch mob she was just protecting the
weak watch looking back how do you
evaluate your role in Franken is
designed to resign so sometimes you just
have to do what's right even if it's
painful even if it's hard even if it's
someone you like or love and the truth
was there were eight credible
allegations and the last person was a
congressional staffer and having worked
in the space for five years of I can't
protect the women in my workspace if I
can't not only stand up for women who
feel abused or feel harassed in our
workplace and I'm not doing my job
if I can't protect women in my workplace
I'm not doing my job
that's kirsten gillibrand position well
in real life back here in reality it
turns out that Gillibrand was perfectly
happy not to do her job as soon as there
were no political points to be scored
last summer just last summer not in 1985
like the other day one of Gillibrand
zaid's resigned over sexual harassment
from one of her superiors the aide said
that although she complained about the
harassment in Kirsten Gillibrand's
office the internal investigation was
brief and her concerns were quickly
dismissed just a girl complaining
that's how Kirsten Gillibrand actually
lives Harris Sanders and Gillibrand
shall look at the bright side though
they're not even close to being the
worst hypocrites in the field of
candidates running for president that
prize you know exactly who that goes to
Bill de Blasio the most incompetent
mayor in the history of New York
we assure you though you've never met a
single de Blasio supporter in the wild
there aren't anybody still running for
president he's built his campaign around
the environment his concern about the
environment
he loves Alexandria Cosmo cortezes green
near deal so much that he stole the idea
for his city and he says he's gonna lead
by example
right until he hops into his gas
guzzling guzzling SUV to head to another
political event we are here in New York
City to show how it needs to be done to
show how it must be done today we
announced the New York City green New
Deal
we have skin in the game the city
government we're going to lead by
example
a year from now de Blasio is
presidential campaign will be mercifully
over but he will live on because his
attitude now defines the entire
Democratic Party do what I tell you to
do just don't expect me to do the same